[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu vim aqui hoje divide na verdade na
inquietação com vocês é é uma
inquietação daquele tipo quase infantil
eu digo isso exatamente porque só as
crianças fazem as perguntas que os
adultos já deixaram de fazer é em função
da sedimentação dos saberes
achamos que compreendemos que podemos
dar as respostas para esse tipo de
pergunta o que torna as coisas o que
elas são tão geralmente é utilizamos é
pra responder esse tipo de pergunta as
coisas são assim porque porque são ou
porque a natureza das coisas assim
ou porque os kiss netão a sedimentação
dos saberes nos impede de continuar
fazendo perguntas necessárias mas eu vou
fazer sem nenhum pudor porque foi assim
mesmo que nos ensinou que é mais
importante é fomentar a capacidade de
fazer perguntas do que buscar é
eventualmente as respostas para essas
perguntas
então é a inquietação que eu trago aqui
hoje é o que torna a sociedade em que
vivemos o que ela é
seus com o seu contorno a seu layout e
para ser mais específico é o que faz do
brasil o brasil
você pergunta não é minha ela já foi
feita antes mas a idéia é dividir com
vocês algumas possibilidades para
pensarmos a resposta algumas respostas
para essa essa pergunta é né não são
respostas do tipo finalista que vão
encerrar a discussão
mas realmente dizer a vocês que é
importante continuar fazendo perguntas
como essa
e aí o primeiro ponto que eu queria
levantar pra começar a pensar em algumas
possibilidades de resposta é o fato de
que nós somos seres gregários nós seres
humanos somos animais sociais é nós
vivemos na relação com outros seres
humanos não é uma escolha casual
fortuito o fato a gente viver em
sociedade quando a gente
cada um de nós na se nós temos um
aparelho fonador ele é capaz de
reproduzir diferentes fonemas diferentes
línguas
mas afinal das contas mas aprendemos
inicialmente em boa terra mas aprendemos
ouro é olho mas o faro que é se a língua
que a gente fala no mar conosco é o
sistema de pensamento português para
venezuela mundo para classificar o mundo
também não ele só nos torna parte de nós
assim como a língua que falamos na
interação com outras pessoas
então nós somos seres de garçons animais
sociais vivemos em sociedade não é uma
escolha caso ao porto ou nada fazer
não vou vir aqui com essas pessoas
amanhã se não precisamos dos outros para
se tornar de fato humanos né e depois
que se torna adulta pode não acreditar
mas é a outras pessoas é é essencial
para humanos segundo ponto que eu queria
discutir com você e quem é é
compartilhar é um tipo de paradoxo que
significa vivendo em sociedade desde o
século 19
nessa sociedade urbana industriais então
isso impõe a cada um de nós uma
interdependência entre as partes entre
os indivíduos ainda maior do que aquela
que uma vez instalado disse que nós
somos seres gregários animais sociais
porque é se uma das oito horas por dia e
executando uma tarefa é é uma actividade
profissional eu dependo que outras
pessoas desempenho outras tarefas para
que eu vivo meu cotidiano a um exemplo
pra vocês
dependendo da sua planta alimento que
colhe o elemento que beneficia o
alimento que transporta é a pessoa que é
lento na rua nos perguntar então a gente
produziu a partir do nós ocidentais de
um modo geral
produzimos uma interface entre as partes
de tipo visceral é eu realmente preciso
farei dia de pessoas de indivíduos que
vivem na sociedade é que eu posso ver o
meu cotidiano
então é isso só pra falar o exemplo e se
refere apenas à arrebentação imaginei e
saúde pra lá de férias foge e tudo mais
que a gente precisa para viver o nosso
cotidiano como um movimento estranho é o
paradoxo de anunciar que compartilhamos
acidental de um modo geral era que ao
mesmo tempo que nublam fato ao objetivo
nós produzimos um tipo de sociedade em
que ele teria dado pastas é intensa no
plamta 10
achamos que nos bastamos é tão enorme
paradoxo que as sociedades ocidentais
produzir a elogia moderna do
individualismo então no banco eo banco
pactual
vivemos uma interdependência intensa no
plano das idéias
achamos que nos bastamos é é estranho
que inclusive - atualmente uma tentativa
de superar é essa é e colaborar
e eu pergunto a vocês mas ela já não
coclear anos
o que a gente faz uma sociedade
urbano-industrial é um monte de
indivíduos é dividindo espaço físico não
é trabalhar juntos né no sentido de que
eu dependo do seu trabalho assim como
você depende do meu então é
nesse sentido que o pará o setor ainda
mais intenso pesado essa intensa relação
de dependência interdependência a gente
no plano das idéias mas a gente imagina
uma ilha é cada uma hilux bastã então
esse é o segundo ponto
o terceiro ponto eu queria dividir com
vocês aqui pra cotejar pergunta aqui que
iniciou a nossa conversa é exatamente
uma especificidade nossa da sociedade
brasileira
nós temos um longo histórico de ausência
de associativismo então que significa
isso nós ao longo da nossa história de
formação como nação que antecede fato de
sermos social de uma sociedade
urbano-industrial nós hipertrofiado é é
a esfera privada entendimento de
interesse genuinamente público é sérgio
buarque de holanda em rádios do brasil é
escrever sobre isso escreveu muito bem
gilberto freyre analisar é o núcleo da
sociedade das da sociedade patriarcal
também ofereceu algumas referências
importantes para a gente entender a
hipertrofia da vida privada e rendimento
de interesses de ano e na mente públicos
netão se a gente é pegar o segundo ponto
que eu escrevi que compartilhamos 11 12
10 com uma enorme paradoxo ao mesmo tema
que dependemos uns dos outros para nos
tornar o nosso cotidiano e no plano das
idéias e achamos que nos bastamos e
associados o fato história de que temos
uma ausência de associativo a gente vai
assim mágica um caminho pra prender o
uso constante de uma de um ditado
popular farinha pouca meu pirão primeiro
não é é lá que a intenção aqui não é
sugerir que nós nos tornemos
é uma sociedade do tipo altruísta é é a
negra
o encontro está o lixo direi uma
possibilidade de nos tornar uma
organização do tipo lista em que era uma
sociedade de casa da gente em 119 é esse
em que desejava mas eu sinceramente acho
que a gente precisa é repensar a relação
entre o indivíduo ea sociedade precisa
pensar em lançar relação entre é a parte
da esfera pública era privada públicos e
isso significa tomar de assalto é a
espera pelo pública com interesse que
são privados como infelizmente é feito é
usualmente nosso nosso país é é um em
fazer coincidir o interesse de vários
interesses genuinamente públicos é ele é
isso que eu digo que eu penso e acho que
essa pergunta nos faz pensar que seja
qual for né
a direção ou seja com o nosso próximo
passo seja qual for a direção desse
passo é é urgente urgente mesmo
redimensionar relação entre o indivíduo
ea sociedade é em cada um de nós né é
urgente redimensionar na zona indivíduo
sociedade que constituem enquanto
indivíduo
na verdade defende para se tornar é
visceralmente quem é
tô é isso muito obrigado
[Aplausos]